tous ces bons ont été réunis par
emmanuel mapon à l'elysée dans un
conseil des ministres qui ressemble plus
à un pot de départ jean castex avait le
sourire vous l'avez vu même si c'était
probablement son dernier alors nous il
ne s'agissait pas du dernier conseil des
ministres du premier quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron puisque vous le savez le
premier quinquennat d' emmanuel macron
je le rappelais s'achève le 14 mai à
zéro heure où le 13 mai à minuit
rv une bâche l'eau qui nous a fait
comprendre que c'était son tout dernier
conseil des ministres aujourd'hui un un
drapeau de la gauche qui est au qui peut
briller alors qu'il pourrait ne plus
elle pourrait ne plus exister quand on a
eu cinq ans de hollande et que son
héritier son fils souchon bâtard
emmanuel macron est présentée comme
étant la continuité de cette gauche tout
ça pour être laminés dans le pays ce
n'est pas la première outrance qu'on
l'entend venant
de la france insoumise
j'ai pas d'autre commentaire à faire sur
ce sujet là vraiment je pars entrées
dont l'inde dont le danger de troisième
guerre mondiale est réel voilà ce que
dit votre homologue russe il s'appelle
sergueï lavrov faut-il le prendre au
sérieux lorsqu'ils disent est ce que
c'est ce que vous pensez aussi on est
toujours dans la rhétorique
d'intimidation le coût humain de cette
guerre est immense nous avons vu des
preuves horrifiante de leurs atrocités
de leurs crimes de guerre dans les zones
que les russes contrôler il est temps
que la sauv russe continuera nous
continuerons à fournir des systèmes
militaires aux ukrainiens avant même le
début du conflit vous savez dans cet
épisode de moscou le président poutine
lui-même avait tenu des discours
alarmistes de cette manière c'est de
l'intimidation la ceni faut pas céder
stratégiquement nous avons tous besoin
de la victoire de ce pays nous devons
récupérer des armes lourdes des chars
des avions puiser dans nos stocks
accélérer la production
la russie et les etats unis ont échangé
hier deux prisonniers sur le tarmac d'un
aéroport en turquie moscou a relâché
très varient d'un ex-marine ce condamné
à neuf ans de prison pour avoir agressé
deux policiers lors d'une fête à moscou
de son côté washington a libéré un
pilote russe condamné à 20 ans de prison
pour trafic de drogue jessica watkins la
première femme noire à rejoindre la
station spatiale internationale
cette américaine de 33 ans embarqué pour
une mission de six mois après que la
capsule s'appelle cloud joyent de space
x est arrivé à l'iace aujourd'hui ont
déjà pris leurs jambes à leur cou le
zozo antoine diers ancien porte-parole
de reconquête s'est barré le lendemain
du premier tour à lezoux l'autre zozos
garenne chenaux rokia ancien
porte-parole barrez vous partez en
conquête mais d'abord j'ai pas et j'ai
jamais été porte-parole de reconquête
j'étais porte parole de la campagne
baptisée mourou porte parole d'aï
zemmour dans le temps de la campagne
et me la campagne étant terminée voilà
je reprends mes activités antérieures
mais c'est à dire qu'il faudrait dire
pas du tout d'abord je suis pas un rat
et je souhaite que cet accord soit revu
ou repoussés de manière à ce que le
parti socialiste puisse avec ses
partenaires écologistes communistes
envisager une autre union mais quoi
qu'il arrive il faudra refonder le parti
ce sont lentes sa décision en fait ce
gros text c'est grotesque
je suis désolé pas comment vous voulez
que les français aient confiance en fait
aux hommes et aux femmes politiques
quand on les voit quitter le navire dès
qu'un tout petit peu de difficultés le
parti socialiste et son incarnation
l'incarnation n'était pas la bonne anne
hidalgo sinon moi je parle pas dit david
olivier von je parle de la direction du
parti socialiste alors il a beau faire
le pitre aujourd'hui nous expliquer
qu'en faites vous
nantes a d'être une femme libre c'est
moi je me permets oui oui mais c'est
insultant madame de
bien des égards sur le toit c'est vous
qui me traitaient sur twitter doivent
s'y connaît voici donc le nouveau logo
du z
le z c'est la loose non non aucune 100
mais je le fais pour dire et je me suis
excusé alors excusez vous c'est faux
excusez vous n'êtes pas excusé m'excuser
excusez-vous personnel